[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nouvelle semaine
d'information locale nous sommes le
lundi à 26 février
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition des températures glaciales
jusqu'à -10° le grand froid a gagné la
france depuis quelques jours et les
personnes sans abri sont
particulièrement menacées une
association saint quentin en yvelines a
décidé de leur venir en aide à la marche
à suivre même des maraudes tous les
week-ends à paris interview
le salon de l'agriculture a débuté
samedi dernier à paris les yvelines et
ses exploitants ils sont bien
représentés est notre dossier de la
semaine dorée est consacrée premier
focus ce soir sur la bergerie nationale
à rambouillet qui a diversifié ses
activités
et puis un projet intercommunal pour
faire renaître un centre nautique fermé
depuis 2015 en raison du manque de
sécurité la piscine de maurepas va
rouvrir
pour y parvenir la ville s'est associée
à deux communes limitrophes coignières
et elancourt face aux températures
négatives venu de sibérie la préfecture
des yvelines a activé son plan grand
froid comme dans plusieurs autres
départements cela permet d'ouvrir des
places supplémentaires dans les centres
d'hébergement une mesure qui ne suffit
malheureusement pas de personnes sans
abri sont mortes probablement de froid
ces derniers jours l'une à valence dans
la drôme
l autre dans les yvelines à offranville
bras seuil en ces temps difficiles les
actions solidaires deviennent encore
plus primordial
une association regroupant des saint
quentinois et et a créé récemment à
saint quentin en yvelines elle est
décidée à agir en faveur des sans abri
cette association c'est la marche à
suivre
elle mène des maraudes à paris et ce
tous les week-ends je reçois un plateau
trois de ses membres sofiane cedar
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
de ce collectif solidaire
nous avons également à ma droite et de
vinh trong bon soir vous êtes le
trésorier de cette association et
hennessy des raïs
bonsoir vous êtes bénévole dans cette
association ou définissez comme le
meilleur bénévoles a dit tout à l'heure
en qualité la téléphone on aura
peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler déjà
parlez nous un peu de l'histoire de
cette association elle a été créée tout
récemment elle a deux mois donc
l'association et elle est partie de base
va t'on étaient tous des bénévoles dans
une association sur paris d'accord on
avait fait que quelques marauder en fait
on voulait en faire plus du coup bah
c'est parti d'une idée de nous trois et
on a décidé de faire notre propre
collectif donc on a fait une maraude
avec nos proches on était une dizaine et
du coup on a vu que ça prenait on avait
plus en plus de personnes qui étaient
intéressés du coup on a décidé de faire
une association
alors pour la présenter on a dit elle
fait des marots tous les atouts les
huitièmes à paris c'est à cette
association
l'objectif c'est de vous fournir de
s'organiser la semaine afin de fournir
tous les week-ends de la nourriture des
vêtements est ce qu'on appelle des kits
d'hygiène aux sans abri sur paris et
notamment sur leucate les deux le
quartier de châtelet-les halles d'accord
donc ça s'organise sous forme de package
ou de kits n'ont que dans ceux qui t'ont
essaye de fournir en fonction du temps
et des températures et des semaines donc
soit un plat chaud soit un plat froid
avec une bouteille d'eau soit aussi un
jus de fruit ou un fruit ou une compote
un paquet de chips ou un paquet de
gâteaux avec cela on ajoute ce qu'on
appelle des kits d'hygiène mais ça sera
principalement des brosses à dents des
dentifrices des lingettes pour se laver
les mains le visage ou le corps en
général
et puis à côté de ça on essaye de faire
ça notamment parce qu'il fait froid en
ce moment donc à porter des gants des
bonnets des écharpes
on reçoit aussi tout autre type de don
vestimentaire comme des pulls des
pantalons
etc on a aussi fait quelques courses de
ça nous arrivait de faire quelques
courses et récupérer des plaids ou des
couettes avec les bénévoles leur venir
en aide aux sans abri on imagine une
action primordiale et surtout en ce
moment avec ce grand froid petit tour de
table
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé vous
personnellement dans cette cause
peut-être enes on va commencer par vous
moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'a le plus touché
c'est que c'est que en fait j'étais allé
pour découvrir parce que je ne savais
pas comment aller au contact je voyais
souvent des sans abri mais on a on passe
souvent à côté sans s'en rendre compte
de leurs véritables besoins
oui et c'est vous vraiment en
participant à d'autres temps d'autres
associations que je me suis rendu compte
qu'ils avaient besoin d'un réel d'un
réel soutien et en créant cette
association avec sofiane et au final
plus gagné dans ces échanges la queue
que le temps que j'y ai mis que et au
final je me rends compte que en aidant
un peu je gagne beaucoup et tout quand
je vois tous les bénévoles qui viennent
nous aider qui nous soutiennent jeu sam
ça ne fait que du déplaisir
oui sofiane et rees parle de des changes
c'est ça aussi il ya on apporte cette
aide aux sans abri mais il ya aussi cet
échange qui se met en place à une
convivialité c'est ça au final caen
quand on donne un petit peu de notre
temps
en fait ils le reçoivent comme si
c'était vraiment quelque chose de goran
alors que nous enfin c'est quelque chose
de futures on se rend pas compte mais
vraiment juste de leur part les cinq
minutes
eh ben ça ça leur apporte beaucoup de
bien et on voit vraiment que qui sont
qui sont heureux quand quand on combat
un petit café quand lors d'un petit café
se tarissent moments heureux
peut-être ajouter vous voit vous êtes
engagés dans cette cause vous pour
éviter d'être redondant est revenu en
fait que c'est parti d'un essai est tout
d'abord c'est ça c'est le plaisir que
procure cet échange qu'on a avec les
sans abri on essaie aussi de ne fournir
pas seulement là pour matériel et donc
l'échangé très important rapport
émotionnel est primordial pour nous on
essaie de discuter au moins de trois
minutes 3 4 minutes avec chacun d'entre
eux pour voilà pour pour leur faire
plaisir et ce qui nous fait encore plus
plaisir en réseau sur le nom la marche
assurée ce qui est aussi l'idée
d'insuffler peut-être un mouvement
d'autres personnes nous rejoignent c'est
ça exactement c'est exactement ça en
quelques mois ça c'est le fait qu'on
marque en fait dans paris qu'on ait un
mouvement assez malsain on va le voir
peut-être en images vous avez rencontré
récemment le maire de magny les hameaux
bertrand au lion ici c'est une action
qui est soutenu vous avez du soutien
pour cette association la marche à
suivre
on va vraiment la commune et la
communauté de
de manier la moe a été très réactif le
maire a vu que des jeunes monique worth
étaient investis dans un projet est
soutenu du début jusqu'à la fin
dire qu'on a on leur a présenté le
projet on a des soutiens on a eu des
idées on est en train de réfléchir sur
de futures actions à mettre en place au
niveau du territoire
lorsque l'occasion d'en dire de vous
tout à l'heure et juste sur les maraudes
les week-ends se déroule comment
vous partiez en groupe c'est ça sur
paris à chaque fois c'est ça en fait on
fait un appel du bénévole sur les
réseaux sociaux
donc ces dames en face suivre sur
instagram et sur facebook
donc on recense le nombre de bénévoles
qui a est arrivé sur place au mondial
les équipes qui sont déjà prêtes
d'accord et après voilà on serait parti
au pouvoir et comment se prépare c'est
justement ces week-ends comment
s'organise la semaine et deviennent
peut-être donc on essaye de faire un
récapitulatif de ce qui nous reste des
marots deux précédents donc au tout
début on a dressé des besoins donc en
fonction du kit qu'ont adressé -
précédemment
et puis on voit donc en fonction de plat
chaud plat froid on se répartit les
cours soient en général c'est un groupe
qui va chercher toutes les courses
et puis une fois que tout est regroupé
on décide où est ce que la préparation
se fera donc ce qui est assez
particulier c'est que la semaine
dernière on a eu beaucoup de bénévoles
notamment parce qu'on a eu on a eu en
une forte visibilité grâce à une très
bonne communication et la préparation
s'est fait chier chez deux personnes
il nous reste un petit peu moins d'une
minute là les prochaines actions à venir
pour pour le collectif
donc on aimerait organiser des tournois
sportifs sur saint quentin en yvelines
d'accord pourquoi pas on avait parlé de
travailler qu'une association
deux dames qui faisait d'aidé qu'enfin
du tricot qui faisait des gants des
bonnets pourquoi pas travailler avec
elle et puis sinon pourquoi pas quoi
partir partir à l'étranger et pour vous
aider
on fait comment alors on a créé une
cagnotte sur le site qui s'appelle
litchi donc un moteur assez pour des
dons financiers que et on après on
récupère aussi des dons faites sur
instagram peut nous contacter si vous et
c'est ainsi à des dons de bouteilles
d'eau de lait ou de vêtements on peut on
peut se déplacer les récupérer
directement et on peut retrouver toute
votre actualité notamment sur la page
facebook je précise également qu'il
compte instagram un conte la snap shot
pour vous retrouver merci à tous les
trois merci d'un vrai qu'avec vous
social cedar président de la marche à
suivre et devine truand que trésorier de
ce collectif et hennessy derraïs vous
êtes bénévole de ce collectif plus
d'informations je le rappelle sur la
page facebook qui s'affiche
on parlait du froid il faut remonter à
2005 pour observer un tel phénomène
météo des températures je vous le disais
négative et des ressentis pouvant aller
jusqu'à -10° ce week-end les sportifs
aussi ont dû composer avec le froid
objectif ne pas se blesser obtenir la
victoire reportage de nicolas landry et
michael enzi d'euros
il essaye de se réchauffer comme ils le
peuvent alors que ce soir là le
thermomètre affiche trois petits degrés
les joueurs de football américain des
templiers d'elancourt utilise un
chauffage électrique en extérieur sur le
bord du terrain
forcément le froid leur malema qui frise
et pour attraper de balancer un petit
peu moins facile mais certaines parties
du jeu soit central pas donc il faut
faire avec cette eau objectif éviter les
blessures au niveau des mains comme il
fait prendre les ballons sont durs donc
c'est vrai qu'au niveau des doigts ça ça
limite la casse parce que l'on a vite
fait sauter une articulation par contre
l'avantagé du froid c'est que en amant
mal en ce sens - le staff également
improvisé un échauffement pendant la mi
temps pour éviter cette fois ci les
pépins musculaires en est revenue un peu
plus tôt sur le terrain pour voir le
temps de faire un bon échauffement pour
être sûr d'être prêt repartir et on met
les gars de dents est vrai que sur
premier drive en attaque ils ont eu du
mal à se remettre dedans mais une fois
qu'ils sont réchauffées après deux trois
coups de casque
c'était reparti
le lendemain les températures tombent à
moins de 3 degrés en plein après midi
sur le stade gilbert chant sac de
trappes pour combattre le froid les
joueurs ont élaboré des stratégies ou
qui colle au corps changement également
dans la préparation d'avant match les
joueurs sortent au dernier moment pour
s'échauffer
pas de coupure au programme jusqu'au
début de la partie pour que le corse
après l'effort donc du coup toutes les
chances à saint plancard éviter le poids
que le corps monte en température
il s'apprête à aller fort le froid des
conditions de jeu compliqué pour le
poste de gardien de but immobile une
grande partie du match mamadou magassa
doit composer avec ce facteur
il faudra toujours parler ça ça permet
de garder garder vraiment des fruits à
chaud en cas de domino de notre part
faudrait que je rêve toujours mobile
c'est à dire faire les petits mouvements
pour pas peut pas choper un coup de
frein le week-end prochain les
températures devraient remonter sur les
terrains dix degrés sont attendues pour
ce week end pour le plus grand bonheur
des joueurs
il s'est ouvert samedi dernier le 55e
salon de l'agriculture se déroule
jusqu'à dimanche porte de versailles à
paris
c'est l'un des événements préférée des
français avec 619 mille visiteurs en
2010 est cette année encore la région
ile-de-france à son espace dédié pour
promouvoir les exploitants locaux 550
mille hectares de terre agricole couvre
le territoire francilien une production
encore trop souvent mal connus écouter
le président des jeunes agriculteurs
d'île de france présents au salon il
était notre invité la semaine dernière
dans le journal elle il ya quand même
des productions con
qu'on connaît mal je pense au cresson
par exemple qui pour le coup
l'île de france est plutôt même
l'essonne et est le département où
kiwili à la capitale du cresson en
france dont claire et bien je crois
exactement
voilà il ya quand même des productions
on fait aussi du foie gras en ile de
france on fait aussi du miel on fait
aussi de la menthe poivrée on fait aussi
un certain nombre de productions qui
sont à ce très très spécifique à
l'ile-de-france qu'on connaît mal et
c'est le moment de mettre en avant
toutes ses productions et notre dossier
de la semaine est justement consacré à
l'agriculture dans les yvelines
direction ce soir la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet a construite sous louis
saez pour abriter les célèbres moutons
mérinos
elle a diversifié ses activités ces
dernières années depuis fin 2016
l'établissement accueille notamment un
atelier de transformation de lait bio
aurélie rose et patrick jacques de
dixmude depuis un peu plus d'un an sarah
lacombe a produit des burrata au sein de
l'atelier de transformation de lait bio
de la bergerie nationale
originaire de la région des pouilles en
italie ce fromage onctueux effet à
partir de mozzarella une grosse partie
de ce travail qui se fait à la main
notamment l'effilochage de la mozzarella
et après on s'aide avec la façonneuse
pour pour sortir nos feuilles
et ensuite on pèse tout ça quatre
personnes travaillent ici en basse
saison comme c'est le cas actuellement
l'atelier accueille également un autre
partenaire la ferme de sigy qui
transforme une partie du lait en yaourt
des produits bio évidemment puisque le
précieux nectar blanc a été certifié
biologique en mai 2016
une consécration pour la bergerie
nationale et sa soixantaine de vaches
laitières
nous fournissons le lait
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée c'est à
peu près mille litres de lait produits
chaque jour qui sont transformés sur
place
le lait entre les tables et l'atelier de
transformation ne parcourt que 300 m
environ
un circuit court qui permet à la ferme
de sigy de produire davantage de yaourt
bio pour la société autant tas de sarah
la combat il n'y a que des avantages à
être ici on est un circuit fermé
donc quelque part le lait qui est
produit n'est produit que pour nous et
pour la ferme de sigy donc il y à aussi
vraiment un
une attention de la part des éleveurs
vis-à-vis des des qualités que le lait
il doit avoir conflit soit convenable
pour nos français
c'est exceptionnel depuis plus de 20 ans
la bergerie nationale travaillent sur le
thème de l'agroécologie cet atelier de
transformation de lait bio était donc la
suite logique et aujourd'hui grâce à ces
à ce partenariat nous savons que nos
produits sont commercialisés
essentiellement en ile de france
donc nous produisons bien et nous
commercialisons bien et locales des
burrata extra frêche qui se retrouve
notamment à la carte de restaurant et
palaces parisiens un fromage à déguster
plus particulièrement au printemps car
c'est à cette période qu'elle serait la
plus savoureuse à saint quentin en
yvelines après trois années de
rebondissements l'horizon du centre
nautique de maurepas s'éclaircit la
ville et les communes d'el en cours et
de coignières ont choisi de s'associer
pour avancer sur le projet en piscine
intercommunale les précisions avec ce
sujet de mélanie poquet et quentin le
frère 7 avril 2015 grégory gary astier
le maire de maurepas ferme son centre
aquatique pour raisons de sécurité
la structure devrait renaître grâce à
une association avec one year est elle
en cours
on est trois communes touchées vous
savez
parce que aussi il n'y a pas eu
l'entretien nécessaire qui a été fait
auparavant
il ya quelques années donc bien sûr on
est trois communes fortement touché nos
enfants aussi
et bien sûr il faut accélérer tout cela
et en même temps c'est beau aujourd'hui
plus difficile de trouver les moyens
une intercommunalité aidé par saint
quentin en yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération a débloqué 2,4 millions
d'euros pour le projet nous sommes
lancés dans la procédure de l'assistance
à maîtrise d'ouvragé en concession avec
une délégation de service public pour la
gestion de ce futur équipement et sa
construction
donc nous avons délibéré les trois
villes pour lancer la démo qui va nous
aider à constituer le projet dans le
détail avant de lancer les appels
d'offres en concession c'est une
concession sur 25 ans nous allons
confier donc un délégataire est assez
risque également nous avons confiée à un
concessionnaire nous allons confier le
financement la maintenance de
l'établissement le fonctionnement de
l'établissement et les différentes
gestions qui peuvent concerner les
renouvellement d'équipements notamment
pendant la période des 25 ans de
concession
une concertation avec les habitants va
être lancée dans l'année la destruction
du bâtiment actuel devrait être
effective en 2021 et leur ouvert au
public depuis le 17 février au tout
début des vacances d'hiver l'espace
rambouillet est lancé dans sa saison
2010 8 c jusqu'au 11 novembre prochain
pour en parler ambroise agrafes un bon
soir vous êtes le directeur de l'espace
rambouillet 250 hectares de nature dont
180 très sauvage idéal pour observer les
animaux on va y venir dans un instant le
parc était en sommeil depuis deux mois
et demi
pourquoi était-il nécessaire ce repos
hivernal en fait pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est un petit peu préparé
la saison d'après d'accord clairement il
faut entretenir les installations aussi
un petit peu apurer les vacances de
toutes les le personnel fait qui est
extrêmement sollicité durant le reste de
l'année
ça on oublie un petit peu parfois et
puis c'est une manière aussi de prendre
du recul et de préparer des nouvelles
animations
les nouvelles activités pour la saison
d'après parce que c'est nécessaire aussi
pour les animaux de l'espace ce temps de
repos ce repos hivernal
en fait je dirais que c'est pas
forcément non une contrainte on ne pense
pas à ça ou d'accord cette période là
quoi alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas justement les l'espace rambouillet
que faut-il savoir c'est un espace en
forêt sauvage quelques les espèces y
vivent
justement dans cet espace alors c'est un
espace qui existe depuis une quarantaine
d'années qui est donc qui a été créé et
qui est gérée par l'office national des
forêts et donc est situé au coeur de la
forêt domaniale de rambouillet sur 250
hectares on peut y observer en semi
liberté
les grandes espèces de nos forêts
l'accord à savoir le cerf majestueux
enfin emblématique de la région de
rambouillet cerfs chevreuils sangliers
et d'un d'un côté la partie forestière
et on a aussi
cent cinquante et deux individus en fait
de rapaces oui voilà on peut voir en
démonstration de vol libre
ça sera à partir de la mi mars c'est ça
exactement vous êtes bien renseigné les
oiseaux en fait ils ont encore besoin de
de refaire tout leur plumage et après
ils ont une période aussi où on
travaille sur leur poids pour les
refaire pour les faire diminuer
enterrant un point être être un peu dans
l'europe plateformes comme des sportifs
accord pour qu'il puisse bien volé et
surtout revenir et le fait que ces
animaux habite dans un habitat naturel
justement est ce que ça joue aussi sur
le fait qu'ils vont être moins stressé
ça joue ça oui alors en particulier pour
les grands animaux parce que les grands
animaux que dont je vais parler qui sont
dans la partie forestière
la grande particularité à l'espace
rambouillet c'est qu'en fait vous pouvez
les observer sans barrières à partir du
moment que vous franchissez la clôture
qui a aidé donne accès donc aux 180 ha
vous retrouver face à face avec des avec
près de tours de 200 grands animaux
qu'il faut aller débusquer d'accord et
il faut les suivre un petit peu enfin c
est un travail d'observation et puis un
peu de magie en fait qui c'est qui
s'opèrent quoi alors là on à la fin de
l'hiver c'est bientôt le printemps même
si on s'en rend pas compte avec les
températures actuelles est ce que c'est
un moment idéal pour observer les
animaux c'est un moment privilégié parce
qu'en fait il ya toujours pas de pas de
feuilles sur les arbres
donc vous avez vous avez meilleure
vision et puis c'est une période
particulière c'est la période pour les
serres où les bois tombe donc ça permet
de voir des défunts liens des spectacles
saisissant à plusieurs aussi animations
des activités qui sont proposées sur
place là pendant les vacances en cette
période
quelles sont les possibilités justement
à l'espace rambouillet alors durant
cette période on a pour les individuels
en fait des animations spécifiques qui
tourne autour des métiers qu'on assure
sur le site à savoir donc animalier d'un
jour ou forestiers d'un jour tout
simplement c'est pas pour une ou deux
personnes
vous pouvez accompagner donc un
professionnel briques pour aller soit
donc donner à manger aux grands animaux
et puis les approcher de très près
certes il ya une idée de loisirs mais
aussi peut-être un côté ludique
pédagogique pour être sensibilisés à la
protection de l'environnement la
protection de ces espèces complètement
et la lidc en fait de faire participer
simplement d'accord c'est un peu l'idée
un peu général vis ma vie là dessus
s'est dit ma vie de forestier où vit ma
vie d'animal y est et on décline plus
tard dans la saison aussi avec le
fauconnier le fait que ça soit géré
justement par l'office national des
forêts ça c'est un plus on imagine des
professionnels qui vont pouvoir parler
voilà aux visiteurs qui vont pouvoir
leur donner des informations importantes
oui après il ya un côté vécu authentique
avec ma dire qu'on peut on n'a pas
besoin de se forcer je dirais pour
sortir des anecdotes fins et c'est notre
quotidien et sachant qu'on travaille pas
uniquement sur l'espace rambouillet on
travaille aussi un petit peu au tour
notamment sur la partie forestière
donc on a la possibilité aussi de donner
un retour sur la gestion forestière plus
générale quoi il nous reste 30 secondes
les grands temps forts là pour cette
saison 2010 8 mai pour cette saison on
aura une présentation
deux spectacles de rapaces avec des
surprises
je peux vous en dire plus pour venir sur
place va exactement rendez vous mi mars
et puis on a beaucoup développé aussi
notre offre qu'on appelle des chantiers
nature à destination des groupes
d'adultes mon entreprise où l'idée là
c'est du team building nature en fête
merci de nous aider voilà merci
embrassades agrafes en avoir est avec
nous directeur de l'espace rambouillet
et tous les horaires un toutes les
informations sur les tarifs notamment
les animations vous pouvez les retrouver
sur le site internet de l'espace
rambouillet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
merci beaucoup merci à vous reste à voir
rambouillet pour cette dernière semaine
de vacances d'hiver le château de
rambouillet a besoin d' aide de l'aide
des enfants le roi de rome a perdu un
joueur auquel il tient beaucoup
et les enfants de 4 à 6 ans ou jusqu'à
samedi pour le retrouver et mélanie
poker et quentin le frère ont participé
ce matin aux recherches
regardez pour retrouver le jouet du roi
de rome ses domestiques à une des
demandes et à des enfants de retracer
une des journées habituel de l'aiglon le
fils de napoléon 1er
on a poli en premier il a récupéré le
château de rambouillet lorsqu'il l'accès
de pouvoir et il a passé soixante joue
ici au château de rambouillet ça peut
sembler très peu 60 jours mais napoléon
1er c'est quelqu'un qui passait
énormément de temps en campagne et du
coût 60 jours c'était énorme pour lui ce
matin très enfants ont relevé le défi
des épreuves pour des enfants âgés de 4
à 6 ans qui les transportent de pièce en
pièce au coeur du château salle
après on était le seul à manger temps
[Musique]
après mais je tournais avec une histoire
c'est super pour moi aussi parce que
c'est bon j'ai pas eu le temps d'aller
d'y aller avant leur naissance passer
l'occasion de mêler l'utile à l'agréable
et puis moi aussi de découvrir
l'histoire du château super la balle
c'est le jouet que le roi de rome avait
été garé
ces enfants sont parvenus à la trouver
et vous une seconde activité attend
également les enfants de 7 à 12 ans au
château de rambouillet c'est un grand
jeu de l'oie et qui se passe chaque
après midi à 15h pour refermer ce
journal on vous en parlait il ya
quelques semaines l'exposition
générations écran se poursuit au musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est jusqu'au 7 juillet et autour de
cette exposition plusieurs ateliers sont
proposés une dizaine d'enfants se sont
essayés par exemple au métier de
journaliste en créant leur propre
journal télévisé camille lambert et
patrick jacques de dixmude
nous allons retracer l'histoire les
journalistes présentateurs caméraman il
n'est jamais trop tôt pour apprendre les
métiers de l'audiovisuel
c'est en tout cas ce que prouve cet
atelier organisé au musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines à 9 ans basile
est déjà bien décidés cameraman ou moi
ta ta des boutons tu peux appuyer tu
peux filmer sur tout ce qui est bien
c'est que tu peux regarder préparer un
journal construire un reportage et
choisir ses intervenants le tout sur
fond de l'exposition générations écran
une émission pour apprendre aussi
l'histoire de la télévision
son évolution de ses débuts dans les
années 30 à aujourd'hui à l'idée la
speakerine de la télévision en noir et
blanc n'y a qu'une seule chaîne n'a pas
le choix c'est la télé à fond c'est
l'état qui a le monopole vraiment sur la
télévision
ça c'est quelque chose déjà acquis
beaucoup plus difficile même pour les
adultes 1 pour se projeter en fait dans
le passé donc ça c'est une partie qui
les intéressent souvent après ce qui est
important c'est de comprendre que c'est
un média en constante évolution que tout
n'a pas eu la télé en même temps je
pensais que tout le monde allait la voir
en même temps à la même époque
samar connectés que mon enfance ça m'a
permis de faire partager de partager que
mes enfants
des choses comme les dessins animés des
émissions cultes dorothée club des
choses comme ça leur donnent un aperçu
en fait de ce que moi j'ai vécu un
plongeon dans le passé mais aussi un
aperçu du futur
prochain atelier le 2 mars d'autres
dates sont à venir pendant les vacances
d'avril hall à nos yeux
je ne vois pas bien effectivement
justement donc g6
la prochaine génération qui arrive c'est
la fin de ce set 8 journal replay et
reportages à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 excellente soirée et très bonne
semaine à tous
[Musique]